hey what's up guys my name is a channel
welcome back to my state boss boss
series today when we talking all about
the Const keyword and C++ a lot of
people seem really confused by this so
hopefully this video will clear things
up so consti is more or less what I like
to call a bit of a fake keyword because
it doesn't really do much in the scope
of changes through the generated code
what it is is kind of like visibility
for classes and structs it's just a
mechanism we get in order to kind of
make our code look a little bit cleaner
and for certain rules on developers
working without code
Const is basically sort of like a
promise that you give in which you
promised that something will be constant
that is it's not going to change however
it's just a promise and you can bypass
that whole promise and you can break
your promise just like you can in real
life like when I promise to make like
daily videos and they're done yeah but
anyway the point is that it's just it's
a promise you promised something to be
constant and whether or not you keep
that promise it's kind of up to you but
again it's a promise in the sense of you
should be keeping that promise and the
reason that we want to keep constant Pro
kind of promises is because it can
actually help simplify our code a lot
and ask a lot of other benefits which
we'll talk about in a minute
so let's just dive into some code so I
can show you what I'm talking about if I
declare an integer just like this I'll
set it equal to five I'm free to change
that integer to whatever I like anyway
down the road however if I declare this
is a constant I cannot change it as you
can see here so if I writing Const here
you've kind of done a few things first
of all you've seen tactically kind of
specified that this a integer here is
going to be a constant
I'm not going to modify it this makes a
lot of sense if you declare something
like max age and set it equal to 90 or
something like that you don't really
want this to be a variable because well
it's not variable you defined a maximum
age and you're never going to change
that that's just kind of a number that
you need to keep around in your program
so this is probably the most simple
example for how Const can be used it's
simply a way to say that I'm declaring a
variable and I'm not going to modify
this variable I don't really want it to
be a very
variable right because the term variable
implies that it can change whereas Const
stands for constant which means that
you're basically declaring a constant
instead of a variable something that
will not change now there are several
other uses for consulates talk about
them the first one applies with pointers
when you just bear a pointer so for now
all I'm going to do is create an integer
however I'll Predators integer on the
heap so that we actually get a pointer
because this is declared without
constant or anything I can do two things
here I can dereference a and then
instead of equal to a value such as two
and then of course to get by print a
I'll get two and all as well and then
the other thing I can do is actually
also reassign the actual pointer so that
it points to something else like for
example this max age that I've got here
now to bypass this whole constant I can
cast this to a normal eight pointer not
something you should usually do remember
how I said that you can kind of break
the cost promise this is one of the ways
however if you try and do it in this
case you can see we've declared a max
age as an actual constant chances are
the compile is actually going to treat
that as kind of a read-only constant and
if you try and dereference this and
actually write to it you'll probably get
a crash however for this purpose it will
still work if I have here five now
you'll see that i now get ninety
printing because what we've actually
done here is reassigned the pointer so
we can do two things we can change the
contents of the pointer so the contents
at bad memory address but then we can
also change which memory address but
kind of pointing towards now let's start
adding cost everywhere so the first
thing I can do is put Const just at the
front here so which is a Const int
pointer what does that mean that means
that you cannot modify the contents of
that pointer so you can see here that
I've created a pointer however when I
when I try and dereference that pointer
and change the value of a you can see
that I can't do that the value of a
being the contents at that actual memory
address however reading a of course is
still fine you can see I'll be
referencing it here printing it and I
get no errors you can also notice that
I'm not getting any kind of error when I
try and actually change a so when I
change the pointer aid to point to
something else such as Max age that's
not a problem
I just can't change the contents of that
pointer so the data at that
we address the second way that I can use
Const is by putting it after this point
assigning like this what this does is
kind of the opposite I can change the
contents of the pointer but I can't
reassign the actual pointer itself to
point to something else note that if you
put Const over here right so basically
it's before the point it's after the int
but it's before the pointer this has the
exact same functionality as if I would
have written it like I did before like
that right Const in pointer or in cons
pointer they mean the same thing you
just be moved constant that the key here
is that it's before the pointer sign
right it's before the asterisk whereas
to make the actual pointer constant so
that we can't reassign the pointer you
need to put it after the asterisk before
the variable name to make sure you
remember that because sometimes you will
see people with different kind of
programming styles writing into Const
pointer but just know that it's the same
as constant in pointer the difference is
when you do endpoint a Const that's the
difference so this is not possible I
can't set it equal to anything else like
a null pointer or anything I can't erase
I actually actual a but I can change the
contents of what that pointer is
pointing to us and finally of course I
can write Const Weiss like this which
means that I cannot change the contents
of the pointer and I can't change the
actual pointer itself to point to
something else so that's kind of a
second usage of Const when when you're
dealing with pointers you can be talking
about the pointer itself or the contents
of of where the point is pointing
towards and where you put cost here with
your declaration whether it's to the
left or before the asterisk or after the
asterisk as you can see it has a
different meaning
now the last meeting a cost that we're
going to talk about today is to do with
classes and methods so that let's write
a quick class we will call it entity
we're going to give it two variables
will have my name X what about an image
like these or anything is just an
example and I'm going to attempt to
write getters and setters for this now
when I saw already might get X I'll just
make it return X I'm actually going to
put Const on the right side of the
method name so after the after any
parameters that we might be taking on
going
right the work Const so this is kind of
a third usage of if it comes kind of not
really to do with a variable but after a
method name this only works in a class
by the way what this means is that this
this method is not going to modify any
of the actual plus so you can see we
cannot modify class member variables if
I try and do something like mm x equals
2 I'm not going to be able to do that
right I've promised that this method is
not going to modify the actual class
it's just kind of a read-only method
it's just gonna read data from the US
potentially but no modifying is gonna be
taking place here so it makes sense to
write const with a getter however with a
setter of course if I wanted to have a
setter where I set my x value here I'm
going to have to write 2x so I can't
declare this as constant because
obviously I need to write to the class
so this is Const and typically you would
declare this with a Const now of course
if X was a pointer and you wanted it to
be constant or round to what you could
do if we just make s a pointer you could
do something like Const and the pointer
Const get X constant see we've literally
got concert in three times on that one
line c++ man out rolls so what this
means is that we are returning a pointer
that cannot be modified the contents of
the pointer cannot be modified and this
function this method promises not to
modify the actual entity class so yeah
that's a lot of lot of restrictions
we've put onto this method let's revert
this back to not being a pointer one
thing I'll point out just quickly haha
point out but anyway one thing I'll
point out really quickly here is that by
putting the pointer next to the type
like I've done here and this actually
become the points I've been my is just
still an integer if you want everything
to be a pointer on one line like this
you actually have to stick a point next
to each variable just something I
thought I'd mention even though it's a
bit off-topic because I'm sure people
are gonna be a little bit confused by
that potentially so I'm reverting back
to just having a normal get up the
question is why why would I want to
declare this
as Const like I get that I get that it
kind of promises not to touch things in
this function and maybe if someone else
was extending that function they would
say okay cool this is not meant to write
to the class however does this actually
enforce something the answer is yes it
does if we had our entity over here in
our main class let's just write an
actual practical example potentially I
created my entity and then I have a
function which prints my entity and I
wanted to access my get up so all
there's something like C out will have
will pass an entity just like this for
now pay or get X and we've got a pretty
reasonable function here now I want to
be able to pass this by constant
reference because I don't want to copy
the entity class again we'll talk about
copying and stuff in a future video but
basically I don't want to copy my entity
class because that would potentially be
space lobbying in this case it's a base
so it probably wouldn't be but in
general I don't want to copy I don't
want to be copying all my objects
because that will be slow especially for
something that's read-only so I want to
be able to pass it by cross reference
now here's the thing if I pass this by
constraints it means that this entity is
const so just like with pointers if this
was a pointer i can modify kind of what
it's pointing towards so I can set eat a
null pointer and that's fine but I
cannot actually modify the contents of a
so by writing Const reference like this
I have the exact same case I cannot
modify the entity I can't reassign it
something else because remember this
doesn't work like it does with pointers
if you reassign this reference you're
actually changing this object not some
other object there's no kind of
separation between a pointer and the
contents of the pointer because with the
references you are the contents right
that's all you can modify those already
referencing you are that entity even
though you're a reference and so the big
thing is I can modify entities so if I
remove this Const from this getup
suddenly I'm not allowed to call that
get X function because this get X
function does not guarantee that it's
not going to touch the entity it could
be doing stuff like this so how on earth
would that work I'm not modifying the
entity directly however
calling a method that does modify the
entity that's not allowed so what I have
to do is Marcus Const and then what that
means is that when I have my const
entity i can call any cost functions so
because of that you'll actually
sometimes see two versions of a function
one which just returns X for example
with Norah Const and one that returns X
for the constant of course in this case
it would be using the Const version or
the HDX otherwise it will be the other
one it looks a bit messy with having two
identical functions basically but that's
that's how it works so because of that
remember to always always mark your
methods as Const if they don't actually
modify the class or if they're not
supposed to modify the class because
otherwise you'll literally be stopping
people from being able to use it if they
have a Const reference or something like
that now in some occasions you do have
something that is kind of constant you
really want to mark the methodist Const
but for some reason you just you just
needed to modify some kind of variable
so suppose that we maybe had a Tanner a
variable here which we just needed to
modify maybe it was something that's
just like for debugging or like it
doesn't really affect the program like
we still want to mark the methodist
cause but we just need to touch this
variable well we can do that there's a
keyword and see what's bus called
immutable immutable of course means that
it's able to be changed so if we make
this VAR variable mutable you can see
that we are modifying it even though
we're inside a constant method right we
can't modify it if it's not mutable but
if we mark it as mutable there we go we
can modify it so hopefully that's
another question answered what is
mutable
that's what mutable is it allows
functions which are constant methods
which are cost to modify it the variable
anyway I hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you did you can hit that like
button to let me know that you enjoyed
this video if you really like this video
you can help support this series on
patreon by going to patreon account for
special teacher no don't get some pretty
cool rewards such as being able to
contribute to the planning of these
episodes and talk about stuff and get
these episodes early sometimes as well
pretty cool stuff and of course you're
helping to support this series if you
have any questions about Constance or if
you feel I haven't covered
thing and maybe I should in a future
video just leave a comment below I'll
try to answer to as many as I can and I
will see you guys next time goodbye
[Music]
[Music]